so we're going back quite a way in
internet history i mean not quite right
back to the beginning but we're going
back to around 18 1986
and
around about 1986 was an event that we
call congestion collapse is how this has
gone down
in internet history
and the internet was was really starting
to take off
there was tens of thousands of machines
it wasn't any more
just
a research project
and
people were using it to transfer files
exchange news
it was quite it was getting it was
getting quite popular
but
around about 1986
the bandwidth
dropped away
really significantly the bandwidth then
wasn't huge anyway so we've got to set
some expectations
they were hoping to get
32 kilobits a second
you couldn't have a phone call at 32
kilowatts could you not a real good
quality one not not a it might you sound
a little bit darlicky
but
two different institutions both of them
in berkeley in california
found their bandwidth that dropped as
low as 40 bits per second
it's a thousand times less than they're
expected more or less
and 40 bits per second
what can you do with that in one second
you can send
five characters
it's pretty poor right it's the only
time that i can think of that the
internet has been significantly degraded
since its starting days has been
significantly degraded for a long period
of time
and what came out of that
was
um
refinements to one of the basic internet
protocols
that are still
useful today there's a classic
paper that comes out of this in
particular two researchers van jacobson
and michael carrolls
wanted to try and fix this problem and
they were part of a wider community of
people trying to fix this problem
and
they were extremely successful
and
the paper they wrote about it congestion
avoidance and control which was
published in 1988
is i i would say that's that's
the most influential paper about the
internet for my money anyway
so i'd like to talk today about some of
the things that were in that paper and
how it fixed the internet when the
internet was broken
to do that
we are we're going to need
a little bit of background
about
the transport layer
okay
so
this is how
we make sure
that packets
go
from one computer to another
and we can make choices
about
how reliable we want that to be
so let me draw a basic setup let's say
all right so we'll draw a laptop here's
one person obviously uh we're talking
about 1987 they almost certainly weren't
using laptops but uh
so let's imagine here's our setup we've
got two computers
they want to send some packets to each
other fundamental to this
is
the transport layer and in particular
today i want to talk about transport
control protocol because if you want to
send data
you want it to be
reliable yeah you want all of the video
that i send you to get to you
no missing data let's imagine we've
broken our data into some packets and
we're sending them along here
one core problem is that that underlying
layer
might
lose packets it's not reliable so what
we have is transmission control protocol
tcp
and tcp's job is to sit
at these end hosts
and make sure
that they can
reliably get these packets
now there's some little tricks that were
already in place so tcp was already
there and in place in 1986 and it was
doing its job of making sure these
packets were reliable
so
well actually here's a question for you
sean you're you're tasked with this and
you'll say here's computer a
here's computer b
we're sending these packets from a to b
how are you going to make sure
that those packets are delivered
one thing i would say is they've got to
be numbered in some way right so that
you kind of know if number one arrives
great spot on yeah so
very very good so we need a header at
the front
and we're going to put in
a number we'll call it the seq the
sequence number
so
uh let's say these are a little way down
the stream so that's number three and
that's number four note for the pedants
out there i know that sequence numbers
are really bites but just to make it
easy i'm going to give them integer
numbers like three and four just to make
my life easy rather than writing down a
big long stream about is it is it going
to be kind of kind of an act here
you've got there you've got the exact
thing you must have heard it before
well i think we've talked about the fact
that this is kind of a guaranteed thing
isn't it so it's guarantee or the idea
is tcp guarantees the packets get there
is that right that's it that's it so
that's a mechanism we're using
is this ack
so these
they're coming back the other way now
this is probably for a lot of your views
this is you know uh you probably know
this already but so axe for
acknowledgement isn't it so
acknowledgement
for acknowledgement and the little blue
bit at the front is just my way of
indicating that it's a header
so we've got the acknowledgements coming
back the other way
so we've got
packets one two three and four have been
sent
and we and we've got three and four
sticking out and acknowledgements coming
back the other way
and if we notice we don't have an
acknowledgement we know something's gone
astray we know
that some packet has been missed
yeah
and this sequence number and
acknowledgements that's the basis of our
reliability yeah
so if we notice
oh i sent out packet three that was some
time ago and i haven't seen
acknowledgement three
we know we've got to resend it
so now
we've got
reliability
there's
another question now
and the question is
how fast
should we send them
okay is this how long do you wait for an
act before you send it again you know uh
oh that's that's a different issue
that's an important issue but it's a
different issue that's that's why we
call the timeout issue and that is
actually very very important to
congestion control and we'll get to that
in a moment but yeah so there is this
issue of the time timeout so
we send off our packet
we set up we set a little timer
and
we say oh i haven't seen that packet for
400 milliseconds
it must be lost
and we send it again
let's imagine we did that let's take a
basic assuming imagine we just do that
we send a packet
and we wait for an acknowledgement send
a packet wait for acknowledgement that
works great but it's really slow
especially if those sites are distant so
if i'm sending something to america or
china i send a packet away from the
knowledge and send a packet wait for an
acknowledgement
it's just going to be
unmanageably slow
what i need to do is be able to do what
i'm doing here i'm sending several
packets at once you see we can see
there must be at least four packets here
and we use the phrase in flight yeah
that the acknowledgement hasn't yet
got back to this originating computer
so the question is
how many packets should i send out
before i wait for an acknowledgement to
get back
can i can i say a really kind of like
sneaky kind of snakeish answer which is
doesn't it depend on the bandwidth
well that's kind of where we're going
absolutely and that that is where we're
going on it but
in those days
actually it didn't
in those days the networks was
relatively simple and it had been built
up by people
just trying to get packets from one lab
to another now obviously by 1986 we've
got lots of things in europe we've got a
lot of things in north america so things
are going longer distances
but initially
initially their main concern was
is
the number of packets we're going to
send too quick for the receiving
computer let's add in a new thing into
our diagram we're going to add in
a little buffer here
the receive buffer
i've got our cv for receive
so the first thing they did was what we
call flow control beautifully simple
idea
the receiving computer says
it says in effect it says
i have room for 10 packets or i have
room for 100 packets
yeah
and it adds that message
into all the acknowledgements
so we can have here
what we call the receive window so we've
got a little
indicator in the packet saying how much
room it's got left so now the sender
knows
if i don't want to overwhelm that
computer
i'm only going to send a packet so i'm
going to send three packets oh it's
currently full i can't send any more
packets
so if this receiving computer is slower
we're going to be fine because the
sending computer knows to hold on a bit
the internet had worked since the 60s
with this kind of only this flow control
in place
um
well it was arpa originally
but by 1986 the problem that you're
mentioning comes to the fore
that actually the problem isn't
with this receive buffer here
the problem is
congestion
and that is the congestion collapse that
we'd like to talk about here
because what i've omitted from this
diagram is that these computers aren't
wired directly together there's the
big cloud of the internet in between
them
i don't know why we always draw as a
cloud in these diagrams but we do that
it's marketing bump isn't it we know
that just a load of computers and lots
of wires is what that should be
and the odds uh radio signal here yeah
some confusing hodgepodge of things
isn't here but also
are
many many more pairs of
uh laptops well not quite
yeah servers let me try and draw a
server then
you're trying to draw something servers
always look like a 1980s pc don't they
that's that's the law
and there are they're all sending their
data as well
so now what we've got is a situation
that wasn't handled by this concept of
flow control what we're now going to
need is congestion control we need some
method of
working out
when
working out how quickly we can send
these packets to the real problem that
this paper solves is the fact that we've
got to account
for all of this crossing traffic
which is going to be highly variable
people are going to be switching their
computers on making new connections
so the core problem we've got to solve
is
we don't really know
the bandwidth
we've got now let's go back to this flow
control and it works with
something we call
a window it's the
amount of package you're allowed to have
in flight so remember this concept of
the in flight packet it's the packet
like these one two three and four here
that we've sent but we've not yet got
our acknowledgement back
so we know
that those packets are out there in the
network somewhere
they've not yet we've not yet declared
them dead because they've timed out and
we don't yet know that they've got home
because we've not got their
acknowledgement so we say our window
size is the number of packets that are
out there somewhere in the wild
circulating at the in the internet one
of the major insights in van jacobson
and mike carroll's paper is
that we want this uh the number of
packets out there from all of these
pairs of interaction computers
to reach some kind of equilibrium yeah
so we kind of fill our network up and up
and up and up and then if it starts to
overflow if we start to lose packets
we're gonna back off
and send more slowly
that seems obvious but they weren't
doing it back then
so the the concept they came up with is
what we call now the congestion window
and it's the kind of budget
of traffic you're allowed to have out
there
that's accounting for congestion
so the trick
we're going to use to do that is
we're going to try and probe to work out
how much bandwidth we there is
so now let's emphasize that all of our
packets that we're sending
are
being kind of pinched here
yeah
that they're competing with the other
traffic
and then
we've still got our acknowledgements
going back
in the other direction
and the question we want to ask is
if we draw a graph here
of time
and here
is c
w and d
our congestion window and this is
we're going to say it's a number of
packets really again actually in
actuality it's a number of bytes that
you're allowed out there but let's just
for simplicity pretend that that window
size
is 10 packets
if we set that too large
we're going to be sending too much data
the network's going to start to overflow
if we set it too small
we are
inefficient
we could be going faster we could be
getting more out of the network
yeah
so here's
the trick they used
well one of the tricks the paper is full
of tricks and i would encourage anybody
to go and read the whole update because
it's lovely they do not only do they do
the practical engineering that fixes the
problem not only do they show you the
code which is often real simple that fix
this problem they also show you some of
the mathematics behind it
that is why they're convinced it will
theoretically work so the first thing
we're going to do is
if we get these acknowledgments back if
we send out
our
window size worth of packets and we get
back
a window size worth of actually get them
all back
we sell
network didn't have congestion
so we're going to let's say
we start here and we get back one
flight of packets
we're going to just increase our window
size by enough for one
maximum sized packet
and we're just going to keep doing that
so if we if we get them back
successfully we increase it by one
get them back successfully
we increased by one
keep doing that
and remember everybody else so
remember there's lots and lots of other
people doing that competing for our
our bottleneck here
and if we all keep doing that
eventually we hit congestion eventually
overflow yeah
now we get we get we get a timeout or we
get a packet dropped because what
happens when those routers
overflow
they've got too many packets their
buffers are full they're just gonna have
to drop something
so the packet does not get back in time
maybe it's been dropped or maybe the
packets just stuck in a queue and been
delayed way though
it hits the timeout that's been dropped
what do we do now
the ccp algorithm just cuts
this window in half
that's not a very good half but
so it backs off really really
aggressively
yeah
now it's sending half as fast
but
when it gets to getting traffic back
again
it keeps on going
up
and up and up again
and then again at some point
it's going to hit suggestion
bam back down by half again
we call it additive
increase
multiplicative decrease
and that is the core insight
which uh
enabled them to escape from this
congestion collapse you might be
wondering why i've left a little gap
here
one thing we want to do is
we want to get going really really
quickly it's crucial that we get that
traffic
ramped up as fast as we can to to get
near our bandwidth limit so another
trick that's in this paper is what we
call slow start
and
what this means is
at the beginning of the connection when
you're not really sure about the
bandwidth you probe very aggressively
so instead of
saying i have room for one packet i have
room for two packets i have room three
packets
initially you increase exponentially so
right at the start of the connection you
send one packet then two then four so
your window size doubles every time
so the graph then
looks like this in this initial period
zooming up like that and then
moving into its linear phase
there's lots and lots and lots of other
little tricks in there so
uh if we detect congestion and we know
that there's a lot of congestion because
we haven't seen any packets at all for a
while we'll slam this
right down to the ground
and start back from zero because we
think there's severe congestion
um but yeah i would encourage any of
your your
viewers to to take a look at that
original paper it's an absolute classic
so what happens is uh when you first
create a file create file in there and
make my files green just represent as a
box and i call that version one at this
point git doesn't know anything about
that because you haven't told it about
it so to get get to know about it all
you have to do is
i think mike's going to demonstrate this
in a second
is that
log4j is like milk it's like water it's
everywhere